more Fox News contribut to new kangri Mr
Speaker uh you became part of a very big
ad that the Trump campaign or somebody
put together I'm not sure if it was a
super pack or the campaign and you voice
it over and you you make a comparison
about corruption with the clintons and
the bidens and a dual system of justice
I don't know what to what degree at that
played a role tonight um but certainly
it did not deter uh many people in Iowa
tonight for voting for Donald Trump
what's your
analysis well as as you know I almost
never write anything down listening to
the two brilliant people you know you
you just had two of the best analysts on
American politics that we have so I've
got five quick points one this is the
people's Victory despite every media
despite every lawsuit despite every
effort to destroy Trump the people of
Iowa have stood up and said no he is our
candidate number two he's the nominee
get over it he is the nominee he's going
to win the nomination the news media
doesn't want to say that cuz they they
need to somehow hype please watch us
while we go through this charade there
is no candidacy for number two there is
no number two there are irrelevancies
you get to be the leading irrelevant or
the second irrelevant or the third
irrelevant but nobody's going to be
number two because he's going to
dominate totally if you look at the
country at large where he's at like 62
or 64% approval Trump is not a candidate
Trump is the leader of a nationwide
movement to take power back from The
Establishment and that's why every time
he's attacked by the Judiciary every
time he's attacked by by the news media
he gets stronger because people go yep
that's what I thought that's exactly
what those corrupt people will do uh and
of course starting with the Russian hoax
it's just clear these people lie all the
time finally Iowa has turned red when
when I first got involved in politics
Iowa was a very competitive State and
sometimes was a sort of democrat state
but over the years Iowa has moved away
and Trump is a big part of this if you
look at the who's winning elections in
Iowa today they're Republicans if you
look at which part's collapsing in Iowa
today it's the Democrats that's a
harbringer I think of what the next few
years are going to be like so that's my
sweeping introduction by the way as a
side note I do need to remind people
that when I was in Atlanta I was the MC
the night you became speaker of the
house but I would often be the MC of
events that you spoke at now you wrote
down notes tonight just so people
understand how profound that is uh every
time you were to give a speech about 5
minutes before your speech You' call me
over and ask if I had a pen and you
would take a a real cloth napkin and a
Sharpie or or a marker and you would
write down three or four things you
throw it on the podium and that was your
45 minute speech uh so that is that is
profound that you actually wrote that
down tonight and that's how far back we
go together um Mr Speaker I've been
you've helped make my life a part of
History I'm very grateful thank you for
joining us tonight we appreciate it and
well if I let me ask you one last
question what about second how important
is it for say Governor D santis to come
in second tonight it's very close at
this time it is irrelevant it's it look
it's like you know being the nicest
person in the school while you lose
every game fine I mean he can go home
and say he did the best he could Nikki
can go home and say she did the best she
could ramas Swami can go home and say he
did the best he could none of them are
going to be the nominee period it is
over if you had any doubt about this
watch the Returns come in tonight this
will be historically the largest margin
ever for a republican candidate in a
multic candidate field ever at some
point people got to say to themselves oh
he is going to be the nominee because
not not because of him but because the
American people want him to be the
nominee he's going to be president
because the American people want him to
be president last question uh polls were
a little tighter in New Hampshire you're
right it's a different electorate Ari
fer mentioned that uh last two polls
were Trump up by seven Trump up by 20
there was an outlier poll of him only up
by four um yeah does it matter at all
what happens in your mind in New
Hampshire no no he's be the nominated
mean look at the weight so so he car in
the worst case he carries 49 states in
the best case he carries
50 okay speaker G Rich always great to
have you hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else